i
i remember as a child but this was this
was my uh thing that i did not like
about chess i felt that it was too much
thinking yeah
it's always very difficult to handle
that and often
often my opponents will start thinking
one move away from checkmate and i
remember like being very forward with
them i said look you should have thought
before
now we're here and there's no only one
movie you can play
and they said let me think
but uh yeah
definitely
it's uh okay now
okay here you go
here it is
and
the players will be agreeing a draw
shortly no i mean tari had a very
difficult situation after the opening
because i think he he did not have
experienced something like this what can
happen
with the weaknesses after exchanging
things on d5
so he got a
very very good lesson today and he
didn't didn't have to pay the price for
it yeah because he saved it after that
he started to make some excellent saving
moves
but it just goes to show like the
strength that
ariane has been displaying throughout
this tournament yeah he's doing much
better yeah much better than a year ago
and uh there comes the fist pump
and
brace yourself judit
we're in for another wild game of chess
yeah okay so we can